mueve el punto anaranjado a 1.9 en la
recta numérica y tenemos entonces este
punto anaranjado en el 0 dentro de una
recta numérica que va desde el -2 hasta
el 2 de este lado tenemos los números
negativos y de este lado los números
positivos
analicemos un poquito más la recta esta
posición de líneas más grandes entonces
será menos 1 y 1 y cada avance indicará
punto 5
11.52 o menos puntos 5 menos 1 menos 1.5
y menos 2 vamos a mover entonces nuestro
punto anaranjado a hacer 1.9
es positivo nos movemos a la derecha
y estamos aquí en el 2 y más o menos nos
mueve por cada décimo así es que si
estamos del número 2 1.9 es 2 menos un
décimo vamos a comprobar nuestra
respuesta y es correcta vamos a hacer un
par más
mueve el punto anaranjado a 0.4 es
importante que siempre revisemos nuestra
recta numérica para que con ello sepamos
hacia donde el movernos y otra vez vamos
de menos 2 está el 0 y vamos hacia el 2
positivo en este caso nos piden punto 4
en la recta numérica y es positivo vamos
a volver a movernos hacia la derecha si
quedamos que este es el 1
este es el punto 5.4 será un décimo
menor que punto 5 así es que nos movemos
hacia la derecha
justo un poco menos del punto 5 y
comprobemos nuestra respuesta
muy bien es correcta vámonos con uno más
ahora tenemos un número negativo mueve
el punto anaranjado a menos 1
en la recta numérica tenemos otra vez
nuestra recta numérica que va del menos
dos pasa por el cero y llega hasta el
más dos positivo en esta ocasión tenemos
negativo vámonos al menos 1 así es que
esta vez nos recorreremos hacia la
izquierda
lo suficiente para quedar en la línea
que quedamos está en medio del 0 y el
menos 2 por lo que será menos 1
comprobemos nuestra respuesta
y es correcta nos vemos en otro vídeo